Karneval auf Kölns Zülpicher Straße
Univiertel feiern bis der Arzt kommt
oder die Polizei
die Tübinger
dass sie mein Wohnzimmer
schon morgens geht hier nichts mehr
[Musik]
geschlossen leider ist hier derzeit ganz
Feier
Abend ich werde sie natürlich
informieren bis die Situation ändert
danke schön
[Applaus]
drinnen geht es rund auch für die 170
Sanitäterinnen und Sanitäter bereits am
Vormittag haben sie gut zu tun
also prinzipiell haben wir meistens nur
alkohol-doxidierte bis jetzt gehabt eine
leichte Schnittwunde die allerdings
jetzt nicht zum Karneval zu tun hatte
und sonst kommen die informations Zelt
und wir machen dieses klassische ganz
kurz hinlegen ausruhen sage ich mal
dieses aus nüchtern und sage ich mal
Sachen in so einer halben Stunde schauen
wir dann wie es den Leuten geht und
können dann halt eben entscheiden ob sie
ins Krankenhaus müssen oder halt eben
abgeholt werden können das machen wir
quasi von jedem Fall abhängig
sie ist 16 und kann nicht mehr sie hat
mehrmals gebrochen jetzt bleibt nur der
Rettungswagen
die Zülpicher immer zu voll jetzt hat
die Stadt strenge Zugangskontrollen
geschaffen sperrt ab wenn zu viele
drinnen sind
und es gibt eine ausweichparty Fläche
auf einer großen Wiese direkt nebenan
doch die meisten wollen weiter durch zur
Zülpicher
und waren auch wirklich aggressiv haben
auch zugeschlagen also wir hatten ja
einige die abgeführt worden sind aber
meine Stimmung ist eigentlich ganz gut
ich bin mit den richtigen Menschen hier
ab Leute kennengelernt die auch Lust
haben hier zu stehen und inzwischen
macht man sich in eine kleine eigene
Party raus deswegen also ist eigentlich
ganz lustig
[Musik]
ihr Freund Sven ist dabei der schon
immer hierhin kommt man Karneval
alle aus meinem Dorf wir sehen uns alle
auf das hübscher Straße wir sind alle
auf der Straße sind Tradition geworden
und gerade Jugend ist immer da gewesen
weil es ist einfach so unter 16 kommst
du auf die türkische Straße das ist so
du kannst Apartment du kannst ja dein
Alkohol trinken mitnimmst und du kannst
Musik hören du hörst ja immer nonstop
Musik auf der Straße und das hat die
Leute angezogen
die Oberbürgermeisterin von Köln
Henriette Rieker kommt zur Absperrung
rein soll keiner mehr
[Musik]
gehen
alles okay soweit dass
Sicherheitskonzept scheint zu
funktionieren
[Musik]
so Stunde ist es noch nicht vergleichbar
mit den Situationen am 11.11 es hat
nicht diese drängenden dieser dieser
menschenaufläufer an den sperrstellen
gegeben und insofern freue ich mich dass
es im Moment soweit wir das beurteilen
können friedlich ist wir alle kennen ja
äh Jugendliche und junge Erwachsene den
das in aller größten Spaß macht und die
Feiern eben auf ihre Art Karneval wir
müssen vielleicht die eine oder den
anderen davor schützengruppen Unfug zu
machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
zu viel von allem zu viel Alkohol
Wildpinkeln in Hauseingängen Müll
Erbrochenes
Anwohner sind genervt sie fordern dass
nicht noch mehr Flächen direkt an der
Zülpicher Straße zum Feiern geschaffen
werden sondern dass die Stadt hier
richtig durchgreift die Jungen sollen
woanders feiern über die Stadt verteilt
[Musik]
hier ich wohne auch hier in diesem
Viertel die akzeptiert das nicht mehr
wir brauchen ein dezentrales Konzept und
dafür brauchen wir auch mehrere Jahre
aber einmal muss man anfangen mit einer
ordentlichen Kampagne dann auch
begleitet und dann gelingt das auch und
den Jugendlichen die von 14 bis 17 sind
muss man den Karneval wieder nahe
bringen dass dann tiefer sind drin
steckt und dass das im Endeffekt viel
mehr sehen Freude gibt und viel mehr
Kraft als es Morgen schon sich die
kleinen Schnapsflaschen reinzuziehen
[Musik]
die Zülpicher Straße als
rosenmontagsmotiv mit der
Oberbürgermeisterin die mal eine
Armlänge Abstand empfohlen hatte
Rosenmontag drängen sich wieder
hunderttausende in Köln Straßen sie
strömen in die Stadt die Polizei hat zu
tun
seine Durchsage der Polizei wir machen
Sie darauf aufmerksam dass heute auch
hier in Köln wieder Taschen die wir
unterwegs sind ich wiederhole es im
taschendie wo unterwegs bitte achten Sie
auf Ihre Wertgegenstände
für die Ordnungskräfte ist der Zug
schwierig wegen der vielen Menschen und
wegen politisch brisanter Motivwagen die
bleiben bis zuletzt geheim
wir haben uns verschiedene Wagen jetzt
in diesem Jahr zurückgehalten die wir
erst an diesem Tag veröffentlichen die
uns einfach sehr wichtig waren das sind
die Frauen im Iran das ist ein Taliban
Wagen und der Wagen der jüdischen
Gemeinde ja die 1700 Jahre jüdisches
Leben in Deutschland feiert
feiern und Party auch Rosenmontag und
Alkohol ist immer dabei die
Einsatzkräfte werden im Lagezentrum der
Stadt Köln koordiniert
besonders achten die Kolleginnen
natürlich ja auch Wildpinkler sie
schauen wir haben aber auch
jugendschutzansprachen ich glaube
irgendwie bis 15 Uhr hatten wir 210
ansprachen
[Musik]
die rosenmontagsbilanz glimpflich in
diesem Jahr der Tag des Zugs gilt als
wenige risikoreich fest in der Hand des
karnevals-
anders Donnerstag an Weiberfastnacht auf
der Zülpicher Straße hier kippt später
bei manchen die Stimmung
die Polizei macht ansagen
und greift durch
wir wissen gegen Nachmittag gerade an
Weiberfastnacht schlägt die Stimmung
auch schon mal gerne um dann greifen wir
ein wir haben es auch vorhin schon
erlebt die ersten Schubsereien
Schlägereien dann ziehen wir die Leute
aus dem Verkehr damit eben der Rest
feiern kann
[Musik]
Karneval organisiert das gibt es auch an
diesem Tag mit Bühnen und Band hier sind
die traditionellen Karnevalisten sie
sind bei der Zülpicher Straße ratlos
hallo
wir müssen zur Kenntnis denn das junge
Menschen vielleicht auch noch der
richtige Zugang zum Karneval fehlt das
ist vielleicht eine Aufgabe die wir
wahrnehmen können zu vermitteln wie wird
Karneval gefeiert man kann immer nur
darauf für den Appell richten dass man
natürlich das Problem mit dem Alkohol im
Griff hat und einfach wir sagen das
Kölner nur so viel Sofa als der Magen
und bis dahin kann nur vertrage
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aber auf der Zülpicher Straße ist mehr
Alkohol als man verträgt Programm
auf der Zülpicher wird weiter gefeiert
und getrunken
[Musik]